thank you everyone for coming I realized
that I am what's standing between you
and lunch so I will try to make this
quick and painless as possible
yes it's an interesting title I hope
it's a little bit mysterious if you
haven't read the abstract you're
probably thinking what is this going to
be about so before we get into that
let's talk a little bit about me as
Kristen mentioned that I am a cancer
prevention fellow I work at the National
Cancer Institute
I'm also co-chair at a nonprofit called
FAS foundation for advanced education in
the sciences that's where I teach a
intro to Python course you can find out
more about me on my website the URL is
right there and if you want to know what
I'm up to on a daily basis sometimes
hourly basis you can follow me on
Twitter and I'll put the link to these
slides up on Twitter I already put them
on speaker deck but some of the images
didn't you know make it so I'm gonna try
to get a better link together yeah all
right
so where does the title of the talk come
from it's inspired by a tweet which you
can see here by Philip go in the summer
of 2018 we had the first great notebook
war all right this is a reference to
Jupiter notebooks which I'm sure many of
you know and love let's maybe do a quick
show of hands who loves Jupiter
notebooks Wow I guess that's why you're
here okay that was 80 85 % definitely
the majority of people here I will try
not to say anything bad about notebooks
so I don't get beat up after the top or
maybe during the talk at the bottom here
you can see there's a guy named Hadley
Wickham who knows Hadley Wickham all
right probably our users okay he's
probably the most famous our programmer
in the world so he started a kind of a
our ecosystem called the tidy verse if
you if you're familiar with that but
basically he says this great notebook
war it's kind of like the spaces versus
tabs of data science and what's what's
what's that well some people like to
have spaces in their code other people
like to use tabs it's one of those
things that people like to argue over
endlessly kind of like the text editors
of the olden days
Emacs versus vim this is a gif made from
a scene from the show Silicon Valley
which is on HBO basically here you know
there's an argument that starts about
spaces versus tabs and then it gets into
text editors and you know it's it blows
up basically right so I'm not here to
start you know a religious war or
anything like that just gonna talk about
what how this kind of notebook were
started what are the tools that are
available for dealing with some of the
limitations of notebooks and how we can
all enjoy notebooks and and have fun and
okay so a quick thing about spaces
versus tabs my personal preferences you
know you can set up your code editor
whatever it is I like pycharm
just have tab be equal to four spaces
and you know that's my personal
preference but when you're when you're
editing a makefile if you want to use
new make for automation
you have to use tabs there so it's not
you know I think this is abate is
definitely not settled
though as you can see here if you're a
developer that uses spaces he's shown
here in red you will earn more money I
mean on on average on average right but
potentially we can try this as an
experiment if you use tabs right now
switch the spaces and then ask for a
raise
okay immediately afterwards okay all
right
so there are some people who use both I
don't know I guess you know I would say
in a make file that makes sense but
otherwise if you have a single code file
where you use both I don't know if
anyone's if anyone's going to be able to
defend that anyway so notebooks I'm
gonna focus on Jupiter notebooks there
are other types of computational
notebooks I don't know anything about
them I've never used the Apache Zeppelin
or or any of the other options I hear
about I've used you put your notebooks
quite extensively it seems like the
majority of people have as well so but
just really quick some background
Jupiter notebooks are data science tools
they're built on ipython you can combine
markdown text with code it can be Python
code it can be R code there are many
different kernels so you can mix and
match languages actually and also the
output from the code the goal is really
to enable literate programming and help
data scientists communicate their goals
methods and results right and then
widely used all over the place this is
this image here is from a blog post by
Netflix showing how they run notebooks
like scripts so they can kind of pass
parameters to the to the scripts and get
different as I pass parameters to the
notebooks and then get different
notebooks for each parameter kind of
that they put that they pass so they're
basically using notebooks in a pipeline
all right which again I don't know much
about I mostly use scripts I think this
is fascinating this could be the future
I'm something to watch all right now so
there's a guy named Joel groose who
doesn't like notebooks okay he was very
vocal about this on Twitter and this was
picked up by the organizers of Jupiter
con 2018 and they invited him to give a
talk about how he didn't like Jupiter
nope
at Jupiter calm which is this is about
just about the coolest thing I can
imagine if you really really really hate
something you know you might be invited
to their conference right you know it
can happen there are links the slides in
the video here the main takeaway points
from this I would say is that joel is
emphasizing good software development
software engineering principles and
practices which he say which he says you
you can't really do in a jupiter
notebook okay and i would just pull out
kind of a main word modularity from his
talk and i'll talk a little bit about
modules at the end and code reusability
so Joel also doesn't like vertical
slides and I was thinking about making
my slides in reveal Jas and just like
having everything be vertical slides
just to troll him just go like you know
using the down arrow constantly for you
know or some of those like mixing and
matching between the two and okay so Tim
who's who's here in the back I spoke to
him earlier he has a talk where he talks
about how he likes notebooks and that's
you know that's also fine and the length
of the talk is here in the in the title
and I just think this little exchange on
Twitter was was was fairly brilliant you
know so my mice this talk right here you
can see is 15 slides long that I don't
like notebooks talk was very long maybe
not 150 slides but it was long and then
this line I find its brevity its most
compelling aspect is like a wicked burn
so you can see this this notebook war is
escalating fast getting out of hand
right okay
it was also mentioned on the data frame
podcast by hugo bone anderson who works
at
data camp it's on episode 44 with Brian
Granger who was kind of one of the
people really pushing forward the
Jupiter project he's one of the
architects of Jupiter lab which is an
integrated development environment which
is really cool and I think will
eventually replace of definitely will
replace the classical Jupiter notebook
and has a lot of features that many
people probably don't know about for
example you can have a text editor in
there you can even have like vim kind of
based text editor there you can set up a
Python console or a terminal and have a
repple where you send code to to the
console from from a script right so
these are kind of awesome things about
Jupiter lab that I think maybe most
people don't know it's not just for
notebooks okay
another response in as part of this this
notebook war there's a guy named
equation who how many people know who
that is
right okay so a few of the are people
not too many he's a a software developer
who made our packages like our markdown
knitter he's very famous for for that in
our community right so he has a blog
post where he talks about that a lot of
the problems with Jupiter notebooks are
just not present in the art world
because they use our markdown and just
so you know our markdown supports Python
so if you wanted to make Doc's
you know basically a document or slides
using our marks then you could totally
do that
putting Python code in there it'll it'll
work and so there is something called an
our notebook but it's just another
output format it's kind of like making
an HTML document right so it's not
anything special it doesn't really
change anything in terms of the content
it's just an output format right in the
our Studio IDE it'll just change the
knit button to a preview button okay and
some people don't like that but that's
like the one thing people can complain
about
because otherwise they're not any
different okay a great thing about this
are markdown it's a plain text file
whereas you put in notebooks if you look
at them wrong it's basically JSON format
which is hard to read doesn't work great
for version control when you're looking
at this but our markdown does not have
that problem and it's very powerful and
very well supported and so all these
people talking smack about notebooks why
should we use them I think the number
one thing is literate programming where
you're combining code text and output
all in one document it's easy to read
easy to digest and they can be very
powerful
right you can make slides you can you
can make PDFs you can make HTML
documents from your notebooks you can
host them online they can be rendered by
github and enbe viewer you can also run
them in your browser using a tool called
Google collaboratory or collab and that
will give you also access to free GPU
anyone who's doing machine learning or
deep learning I'll say that again free
GPU in your browser ok and also Google
is a new thing TPU so like a tensor
processing you know so ok that's like
the next level it's like a super GPU so
that's something I think that's very
valuable oh and then when you use collab
you can have version control through
Google Drive ok on your notebook so that
is that is another huge selling point
who's used Kaggle here ok all right I'd
say at least half probably closer to 60%
so you know Kaggle kernels if you're if
you want to share your work with someone
it's in the form of a jupiter notebook
most often and that is also a wonderful
platform I really like binder and with
binder you can just go to their site the
links right here and you can put in a
the link to a github repo and it'll
create a computational environment in
your browser where you can run the code
that's in the github repo and use the
resources that's in the github repo I
use this all the time for classes we saw
this during the tutorials for the desk
tutorial if you missed it that was you
just click the launch binder button and
you have that computational environment
ready in your browser and it works
through classical notebooks or Jupiter
lab or if you're an hour person you can
also set it up to open up with our
studio ok so pretty awesome pretty
awesome stuff ok some more notebook
tools there is a version control tool
specifically for notebooks it's called
envy dime right that might be useful if
you love writing code in notebooks ok
there's also a way that you can well
several ways that you can not write code
in notebooks but have your code in
notebooks okay so for example there's a
tool called Juby text and this gif down
here is showing how it works you
basically you work in a script that's
paired with a jupiter notebook and when
you you know whatever you write in the
script will be updated in the notebook
this is a tool that's fairly new but
it's exploded you know you can look on
github it has way more stars than any of
these other packages which are some of
it this note town has been around longer
for sure so note down what does that do
it allows you to convert Jupiter
notebook files to mark down and back
basically right and as part of this you
can configure your Jupiter notebooks to
open up okay so basically open up
markdown files as you put your notebooks
so instead of using the dot I PI + B
extension it'll use dot markdown alright
which is pretty cool if you want to go
to something that you know commonly used
format and you can run everything just
the same but using markdown instead of I
PI and me
so final tool this is a Python package
that I wrote actually so it has like
zero stars on github and it's you know
no one knows about it but basically what
you can do is you can kind of
concatenate markdown files and scripts
and to make a notebook and then you can
also run it in one go so you put all of
these kind of source files together and
you you have you can you can also have
kind of like a raw notebook which hasn't
been run and then one with all of the
output okay
but down here this is Jupe text which i
think is probably the best solution if
you want to work work in a script but
also have a notebook alright
but the major plug I'll make going back
to Joel's talk is you know right modules
all right you know you modules kind of
follow a standard structure everyone
knows how well everyone should know how
they look you have your imports there's
an order to the imports you'll have your
definitions classes and functions I went
to Steven lots great tutorial yesterday
you can see there's a there's a video I
think from two years ago
which is a similar talk was the five
types of Python functions you know in
the talk it was kind of like there are
six actually but seven but no not really
there there are just five right so
Steven lot also talked about type hints
which I think you know everyone should
use this helps if you're using Python
for example it'll help your IDE help you
write when you put type hints into your
function and class definitions this is
something that travels with the
functions and classes it's accessible in
the dunder annotations attributes and
it's it's it's something that's very
helpful for other people reading your
code right and similarly with docstrings
docstrings
also travel with your functions and
classes wherever they go and when you
when you run the help function on a
function or a class it'll show you the
type hints and the doc strings okay in
the doc string
the duck string is in the dunder dock
attribute and so those are kind of like
how you define your classes at the
bottom what you should have is this if
name equals main guard basically this
keeps your module from being being you
know anything that's at the bottom it'll
keep it from being run unless the module
is being run as a script okay so
basically this kind of lets you do have
kind of double functionality for a
single file you can import the file as a
module and you can run it as a script
all right and one cool use for this is
if you're if you don't ever think you're
going to be running this module as a
script is to just put in there doc test
test mod so this this this function call
right here and then you can run doc test
on that module and it will check all of
the examples in your doc string for you
okay and give you the output so you know
this example failed this one passed
right it's it's highly useful it's a
very easy way to get started with
testing all right but the other thing
you know modules and testing I think
kind of go hand in hand when you're
writing modules you should write tests
for them if you don't want to write
tests at least put examples in your doc
string and your doc strings then you can
use the unit test API to kind of extract
those examples into tests that will be
in a unit test test suite all right and
you can run that test suite with unit
tests or PI tests whatever is your
preferred test runner okay
and then the last couple points use
cookie cutter templates to set up a
project structure if you're working on a
team agree on a cookie cutter template
that works for the most if not all of
your teammates right and use the things
kind of leverage that structure the
things that are included in there
to have a good project that you'll
you'll when you look back you know six
months or you know a year ahead you look
back on and you'll be proud that you
were following good principles
throughout the time you were working on
that project right
final thing deploy your projects to pi
PI all right this is great for sharing
code it's it's wonderful it's a
wonderful experience
you can then brag about it you know hey
you can pip install my Python package
right and it's it's it's really
wonderful for for sharing code for
getting feedback on your code for making
the work that you've done accessible to
to everyone okay with that I'll say
thanks for listening and take any
questions you have yes oh maybe you wait
for the wait for the mic
I can't remember the last time it was
once definitely yes that's a great
question so the question was basically I
had the mic so I'm not gonna repeat it I
I do love PyCharm that is certainly true
I prefer working in patch arm over
Jupiter lab so I'm not ready to ditch
PyCharm anytime soon or ever but oh the
the support for duper notebooks in
PyCharm is is better it doesn't have any
of the kind of shortcuts that I'm used
to from when I used to use Jupiter
notebooks a lot so if you if you use
Jupiter notebooks the experience in
patch room is going to be different the
keyboard shortcuts are different I use
it mostly for viewing notebooks it's a
nice way to view notebooks or just run
code in the same environment where you
write your scripts and that being said
in Jupiter lab you can do the same thing
you can write scripts write modules and
of course it has excellent support for
Jupiter notebooks as part of the the
project Jupiter
I have not heard of dat alors I think
that's another one of those you know
computational notebooks that I just have
not played around with but have you have
you tried it
yeah well that's interesting I'll I'll
look into it I'm a fan of JetBrains
obviously I think they make great ideas
not just pie chart yeah
okay I'll now I'll ask a question right
who here has changed their mind about
notebooks after listening to this talk
zero people everyone is you know the
everyone is diehard whatever they
believed previously right okay well I
didn't I didn't change any minds who is
excited about trying out at least one of
the tools that I talked about okay all
right that's good yeah I would say like
at least 80% you know what can maybe
round up to 90% sure why not
okay all right
well thanks so much everyone
[Applause]